Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ekrem Özvalım. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Asst. Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit dir in dieser Aufnahme sprechen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Als erstes benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Tobias Beckers.
Tobias Beckers. Herr Beckers, könnten Sie bitte Ihr Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, natürlich. Tobias ist T-O-B-I-A-S.
Okay.
Beckers, buchstabiert sich B-E-C-K-E-R-S. Beckers.
Am Ende S?
Ja, am Ende S wie Samuel.
Okay, vielen Dank. Herr Beckers, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1. Februar 1984.
1984.
Ja, genau.
1984. Vielen Dank. Herr Beckers, wie groß sind Sie?
171 cm.
71 cm.
Ja.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 80, entschuldigung 60 kg.
64 kg.
64 kg, ja.
Okay, vielen Dank. Was wissen Sie uns heute? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, also ehrlich gesagt schlagt mein Herz richtig schnell.
Ich spüre auch Herzklopfen und so ein enger Gefühl in der Brust.
Herzschlagen und enger Gefühl. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen.
Herr Doktor, woher kommt eigentlich Herzrasen?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Angst.
Ja, für die Herzrasen könnte man viele Ursachen haben.
Wir führen ein paar Fragen stellen. Dann können wir widersprechen.
Und Herzlagen und enger Gefühl haben Sie seit heute Morgen.
Diese Beschwerden sind plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten.
Plötzlich aufgetreten.
Bekomme ich eine Krankschreibung? Ich kann so nicht arbeiten, Herr Doktor.
Ja, natürlich. Sie sind schon hier.
Krankschreibung.
Ja, deswegen sind Sie schon hier bei der Notaufnahme.
Okay, danke.
Deswegen ja.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass ich nicht so gut hören kann.
Langsam aufgetreten, haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Diese Herzschlagen.
Ja. Plötzlich. Herr Doktor, seit heute Morgen.
Plötzlich angefangen. Sie sind plötzlich angefangen.
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Und vielleicht möchten Sie wissen, ich habe auch Bauchschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, noch Bauchschmerzen.
Die Bauchschmerzen sind die gleichzeitig, oder?
Nein, seit etwa drei Tagen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Okay, drei Tage. Sie haben Bauchschmerzen. Ich habe das notiert.
Herr Becker, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Herzschlagen?
Das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Ja, haben Sie Atemnot aktuell?
Nein, ich nicht.
In dem Moment ist es dauerhaft, oder?
Haben Sie noch Herzschlagen?
Ich kann nicht genau beschreiben.
Aber leider ist es da runter. Aber im Moment besser. Ja, ich fühle mich besser.
Okay, haben Sie noch Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, kein Bauchschmerzen. Alles gut.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen.
Herr Becker, ist das das erste Mal aufgetreten oder haben Sie vorher ein Schwerpunkt?
Eigentlich schon seit zehn Jahren immer wieder.
Zehn Jahre?
Ja, früher waren sie schwächer, vielleicht. Aber es wird langsam immer schlimmer.
Mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Ich würde gerne wissen, Herr Becker, ob der Herzrasen und Bauchschmerzen immer gleichsätzlich waren oder?
Ja, das habe ich zum ersten Mal bemerkt.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen seit Langem.
Vor drei Monaten hatte ich deswegen eine Magenspiegelung bei meinem Hausarzt.
Vor drei Monaten?
Ja, wegen dieser Bauchschmerzen.
Da war angeblich alles unauffällig, Herr Doktor.
Unauffällig.
Eine Magenspiegelung?
Ja, diese Magenspiegelung meine ich.
Haben Sie das Ergebnis dabei?
Ich kann Ihnen den Namen von meinem Hausarzt geben.
Okay, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Frau Müller.
Frau Müller, okay. Ich werde mit Frau Müller in Verbindung setzen.
Okay, kein Problem.
Und dann können Sie bitte die Bauchschmerzen genau beschreiben, wie dunf, kolikartig und brennend stehend.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich würde sagen, drückend und manchmal kolikartig.
Drückend und kolikartig.
Herr Doktor, ich habe mich daran erinnert.
Besonders nach dem Essen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Das fängt an, nachdem ich im Thai-Restaurant war.
Ich habe dort Tofu.
Ich habe dort Tofu mit Reis und Gemüse gegessen. Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Ja, ja, ja. Tofu. Eine thailändische Speise. Ich vermute.
Meine Frau hat mich übrigens gezwungen, dorthin zu gehen.
Ich wollte eigentlich lieber etwas anderes essen, aber das habe ich gegessen.
Ja, ich wüsste es.
Ja, danach habe ich das bekommen. Habe ich diese Schmerzen bekommen.
Okay, ich wüsste es. Wann haben Sie das gegessen?
Tofu?
Vor drei Tagen, ja.
Bevor ich diese Schmerzen bekommen habe, ja.
Okay.
Herr Becker, erstrahlen Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Eigentlich nicht.
Die Schmerzen sind auf dem Bauch oder Magen.
Hier, Herr Dr.
Oberbauch. Am Bauch. Okay.
Oberbauchschmerzen seit drei Tagen. Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, nach dem Versen.
Herr Dr., Entschuldigung für die Unterbrechen, aber ich habe auch Übelkeit.
Und wenn ich mich übergebe, fühle ich mich besser.
Vielleicht kann es eine Lindner-Konfaktur sein für Sie?
Okay.
Nach dem Übergeben der Schmerzen geht es ein bisschen besser.
Okay, ich habe das notiert.
Herr Becker, Ihre Frau oder Ihre Kinder haben auch eine Schmerzen seit drei Tagen.
Oder nur bei Ihnen.
Wie bitte?
Gibt es noch jemand, der gleiches Essen gegessen hat?
Zum Beispiel Ihre Frau hat Tofu gegessen oder?
Sie hat auch Tofu gegessen, aber sie hat keine solche Beschwerden.
Keine solche Beschwerden. Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, vor drei Monaten wegen einer Beschwerden bei Ihrem Hausarzt eine Ökede durchgeführt wurde.
Was war das?
Sie haben eine Magenspiegelung gesagt.
Okay, genau.
Das war unauffällig.
Okay.
Herr Becker, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie beschreiben Sie, nur kein Schmerzen, sind sehr, sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht.
Wie würden Sie mir die Schmerzen beschreiben auf eine Schmerzskala?
Herr Doktor, etwa drei von zehn.
Kann ich so sagen, nach dem Essen etwas stärker.
Und wie stark nach dem Essen?
Viel, aber bestimmt stärker.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch dagegen einen Medikament angenommen oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Herr Becker, haben Sie Fieber?
Entschuldigung.
Ein Moment.
Herr Becker, haben Sie Fieber?
Kann ich nicht hören, leider.
Ich denke, Blutdruck ist aktiv.
Hören Sie mich gut?
Kann ich Sie nicht gut hören?
Nein.
Leider habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich denke ...
Ja.
Hallo, Herr Becker?
Kannst du mich hören?
Ja, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Und ...
Ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Okay.
Herr Becker, haben Sie ...
noch gesagt, kein Fieber, Stahlfluss?
Ich habe kein Fieber, Herr Doktor.
Nach Schmeiß, Schmeißen.
Ich weiß, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Aber manchmal leide ich Durchfall, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe jetzt ... Entschuldigung, ich leide darunter.
Seit gestern.
Durchfall seit gestern?
Ja, ja.
Wie sah es aus?
Der Stuhl ist eher brech und flüssig, Herr Doktor.
Auch dunkelbraun.
Aber es gibt kein Blut.
Ah.
Bestrich.
Kein Blut.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, das habe ich bemerkt.
Okay.
Aber Herr Doktor, möchten Sie wissen,
ich kann mich auch schlecht konzentrieren auf irgendetwas?
Seit wann haben Sie Konzentrationsstörungen?
Ist ...
Dauerhaft oder ...
Ich war dauerhaft.
Ja, manchmal leide ich darunter.
Manchmal, okay.
Fühlen Sie sich müde oder ...
Ja, ich fühle mich auch müde.
Schlafen Sie gut in der Nacht?
Haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchschlafen?
Herr Doktor, wegen dieser Schmerzen kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Herr Becker zum Beispiel,
Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder ...
Herr Doktor,
ich habe übrigens Ferse-Schmerzen.
Wissen Sie, wo genau die Ferse ist?
Ferse-Schmerzen, ja.
Könnten Sie sich das vielleicht anschauen?
Ja, natürlich.
Am Ende dieses Gesprächs werde ich Sie alle anschauen.
Ja, ich frage mich, ob man das operieren muss.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben nach meinen Krankheiten gefragt.
Ich habe Blutdruck seit zwei Jahren.
Zwei Jahre.
Sie haben Bluthochdruck.
Ja, Bluthochdruck, ja.
Natürlich.
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ferse-Schmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Dauerhaftig, chronisch meinen Sie?
Wenn ich laufen ...
Ja.
Wegen dieser Bestreiten waren Sie schon einmal bei Ihrem Hausarzt oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Gibt es keine bestimmte Diagnose?
Nein.
Dann haben Sie Ferse-Schmerzen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikament gegen Bluthochdruck?
Natürlich, Herr Doktor.
Ich nehme Nebivolol und Amlodipin.
Nebivolol und ...
Wie viel Milligramm wissen Sie?
Nebivolol ist 2,5 Milligramm und auch Amlodipin 2,5 Milligramm.
2,5 Milligramm.
Beide?
Ja.
2,5 Milligramm.
Herr Doktor, ist Bluthochdruck eigentlich ärmlich?
Ja, könnte sein.
Aber gibt es viele Verständnissachen?
Zum Beispiel Lebensstil, Rauchen, Alkohol trinken, Sport treiben, Gewicht reduzieren.
Gibt es viele Verständnisse?
Verständnisse.
Nicht nur ärmlich.
Und haben Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Becker?
Herr Doktor, ja, ich hatte ...
Ähm ...
Mandelentfernung.
Ja, weil ich 11 Jahre war.
11?
11 Jahre war ich in Schildegurje.
Okay, das verkommt Kastron aus oder?
Nach der Operation habe ich viel geschlafen, Herr Doktor.
Hätte ich Übelkeit und musste ich mich übergeben.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ist das normal?
Ja, nicht normal, aber nicht so schlimm. Manchmal könnte es sein.
Okay.
Könnte es sein, nach der Vollnarkose. Ist das möglich?
Okay, gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Ja, okay.
Mandelentfernung.
Okay.
Herr Becker, haben Sie Allergien?
Ich habe Erdnussallergie, Herr Doktor.
Erdnussallergie.
Wie ist das?
Wie bitte?
Wenn ich Erdnuss esse, bekomme ich dann Brennen im Mund, Schwitzen und Yukreis.
Im Mund, Schwitzen, Yukreis, Hote auf Schlag oder ...
Nein, das habe ich nicht, aber diese drei habe ich.
Okay.
Herr Becker, nehmen Sie Regelmäßig gegen Bluthochdruck, Nebioror und Amlodipin?
Sie haben es schon gesagt.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Regelmäßig?
Nein.
Zum Beispiel einen Magenschutz?
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt, habe ich keine anderen Medikamente.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Oder nehme ich keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay. Sind Sie vollgeimpft?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Gegen Corona und Normal-Cocum-Influenza.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Sie gehen sich da hin.
Herr Becker, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Herr Doktor, ja, sie leben noch, aber sie haben manche gesundheitliche Probleme.
Mein Vater hat auch Bluthochdruck und Grüneschtar.
Grüneschtar, okay.
Unter Kontrolle oder?
Ich hoffe es, ja.
Er hat mit 63 Lebensjahren einen Herzanschlag erlebt.
Klar, man hat gesagt, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Weil er 63 Jahre alt war. Entschuldigung, alles.
Ja, okay. Herzanschlag. Erlitten.
Okay, und?
Herr Doktor, ist Grüneschtar erblich?
Ja, könnte sein, aber ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Sie sollen für dieses Thema mit einem Augenarzt spielen.
Kann ich nicht genau sagen. Ja, könnte sein.
Und meine Mutter hat Altersdiabe, Alterszucker, Herr Doktor.
Und sie hat auch Hühnerauge.
Hühnerauge?
Ja, soll sie auch einen Augenarzt besuchen?
Für dich Hühnerauge? Ja.
Sie sollen einen Orthopäden auch suchen, ich denke.
Okay.
Herr Becker.
Haben Sie Schwester? Herr Becker?
Geschwister? Ja, Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Schwester.
Eine Schwester? Ist sie gesund?
Nein Herr Doktor, sie leidet Magendanproblemen.
Magendanproblemen? Ja.
Okay.
Herr Becker, sind Sie verheiratet?
Herr Doktor, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, haben Sie schon gesagt. Haben Sie Kinder?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ja, wir haben eine sechsjährige Tochter.
Sechsjährige Tochter. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Kommunikationsdesigner. Ich arbeite Vollzeit, Herr Doktor.
Aber zum Glück bin ich damit zufrieden.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das freut mich.
Kommunikationsdesigner.
Herr Becker, ich bin noch mit meinem Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie noch etwas, wenn Sie fragen?
Herr Doktor, möchten Sie vielleicht, ob ich rauche oder trinke?
Ja, Entschuldigung, Sie haben mich auf meinem Blatt noch nicht geschrieben.
Deswegen vergesse ich. Rauchen Sie?
Nein Herr Doktor, ich rauche nie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Naja, vielleicht zwei bis drei Gläser Schnaps oder Wein am Abend.
Am Wochenende etwas mehr.
Etwas mehr. Zwei oder drei Gläser Wein.
Schnaps trinke ich.
Am Wochenende noch mehr.
Ja, etwas mehr.
Meine Frau sagt immer, ich sei ein Schluckspecht.
Wissen Sie, was das heißt?
Oder denken Sie auch, dass ich ein Schluckspecht bin?
Nein, ich denke nicht so.
Das ist nicht so. Ich denke das so nicht.
Aber können Sie bitte versuchen, Ihre Alkoholkonsumierung etwas zu reduzieren?
Okay, ich versuche.
Es wäre besser für Ihre Gesundheit, besonders für den Magen, Daumen und die Essengewohnheit.
Vielen Dank Herr Becker. Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Danke für die Gedanken.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Herr Doktor, was habe ich? Was denken Sie?
Sie haben am Anfang gesagt, dass Sie am Ende meine Herzrasen erklären.
Oder die Gründe dieser Herzrasen erklären.
Ja Herr Becker.
Was habe ich? Hauptsache ich meine Backschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe alle Verdacht auf den Magen und Daumen Empfindlichkeit.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vernutung.
Ich werde Ihren Körper untersuchen, dann ein paar Blut abnehmen,
dann gegebenenfalls einen Ultraschall durchführen
und auch gegebenenfalls einen gastroenterologischen Konsil anfordern.
Dann werde ich mit Ihrem Hausarzt, Ihrer Hausarzt Frau Mila,
haben Sie schon gesagt, in Verbindung setzen.
Ich brauche Ihre Magenspiegel und Ergebnisse.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, können wir über diese Thema sprechen.
Warum sind mein Magen und Daumen empfindlicher Doktor?
Sie haben so gesagt.
Vielleicht kann es sein, dass Sie wegen Stress zu Hause sind.
Ich streite immer mit meiner Frau.
Ich habe viel Stress zu Hause.
Ja, könnte dafür gelungen sein.
Sie haben gefragt, aber ich habe viel Stress zu Hause.
Obwohl ich bei der Arbeit keinen Stress habe, habe ich viel Stress zu Hause.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Ich verstehe, Sie haben seit ca. 10 Jahren ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie sind nicht Raucher, aber täglich trinken Sie 2 oder 3 Gläser Wein am Abend.
Sie haben vor 3 Monaten Oberschmerzen.
Sie haben eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt.
Es gab keine auffälligen Ergebnisse.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht,
dass meine Vordeagnose eine Magendarmempfindlichkeit ist.
Dann können wir weiter untersuchen und durchführen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, können wir wieder sprechen.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, danke.
Vielen Dank.
Bis dann.
Bis gleich.
Das war es.
Frau Oberschmerz, darf ich ein paar Fragen stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Für die Patientin.
Für Herrn Beckers.
Herr Beckers, strahlen Ihre Schmerzen in den Unterbauch oder ins Hals?
Danach wurde gefragt.
Ich habe keine Anstrahlung.
Ich habe akustisch nicht gut gehört.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewichtveränderungen?
Nein, es ist immer stabil.
Okay.
Wann war Ihre letzte Blutdruckmessung?
Kontrollieren Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Ja, ich achte darauf.
Das war normal. 120 zu 70.
Wann war die?
Vor zwei Tagen.
Das ist gut.
Haben Sie etwas gegen die Naurensmittelunverträglichkeit?
Ja, wenn ich etwas Scharfes esse, bekomme ich Probleme wie Dier, wie Durchfall.
Übelkeit.
Gestes Essen war auch mit Scharfes? Was denken Sie?
Gestes Essen war Scharfes oder?
Ja, es gibt Gewürze, aber nicht so scharf.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Kling, Kling.
Hallo.
Guten Morgen. Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Guten Morgen, Frau Müller.
Eine Werte von Frau Bergheim.
Frau Bergheim.
Kaliumwert von 2,6 Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie diese Werte bitte Ihren Operarzt weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich. Frau Müller, vielen Dank für die Information.
Okay, guten Tag. Tschüss.
Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag, Frau Obersten.
Woher kommen Sie, Herr Ösyuval?
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Frau Obersten.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit drei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland mit meiner Familie.
Okay. Was haben Sie bisher in Deutschland gemacht?
Ich habe Deutschkurs, alle Niveau, B1, B2 und Fachsprache, B5 gemacht. Und so wie 3-mal die Ospitation.
Welche Fachrichtungen haben Sie in der Ospitation gemacht?
Gasventilologie, Urologie und Atemheizschirurgie.
Okay. Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, ob es eine Unterschiede zwischen Türkei- und Deutschland-Gesundheitssystem gibt?
Wie soll ich sagen? Ja, das Gesundheitssystem ist bei uns ein bisschen gut kontrolliert.
Bei uns ist das Gesundheitssystem nicht so gut kontrolliert und die Patientbelastung ist sehr hoch.
Ich bewundere mich und das Gesundheitssystem.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen in der Türkei?
Seit 13 Jahren bin ich Facharzt für Urologie. Ich arbeite in der Türkei über Uro-Onkologie.
Aber seit 3 Jahren bin ich arbeitslos in Deutschland.
Ich möchte wieder als Arzt in Deutschland arbeiten.
In welchen Fachrichtungen würden Sie gerne arbeiten? Wieder in Urologie oder in anderen Fachrichtungen?
Natürlich in meinem Bereich. Ich möchte wieder fortführen.
Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Ich habe einen Patienten, Herr Tobias Becker, 42 Jahre alt, 1984.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Patienten vorstellen, können Sie noch andere wichtige Dinge mitteilen?
Bevor ich meine Patienten vorstellen kann, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe gerade eine Frau in der Türkei angerufen.
Frau Bergheim. Eine Kaliumwerte von 2,6 MW pro Liter.
Diese Werte sind deutlich erniedrigt und entspricht einer Hypokaliemi.
Was ist die wichtigste Ursache für eine Hypokaliemi?
Die wichtigste Ursache ist die Diuretik.
Die Diare, Erbrüche, Aqualose, Respiratorische und Metabolische können Ursachen sein.
Die Befunde sind Muskelschwäche, Kraftverlust, Krampf, Reflexstörungen, Schwierigkeiten, Obstipation und die wichtigste Kammerflamme.
Wie können Sie diese behandeln?
Die wichtigste Form, die wir unter über 2,5 MW pro Liter haben, ist die kaliumreiche Ernährung, z.B. Obst, Bananen, Obst, Bananen.
Bei den schweren Formen wird die kaliumreiche Ernährung mit Parantheral, Kalziumchlorid behandelt.
Was haben Sie noch?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten, Tobias Becker, 42 Jahre alt, 1.2.1985 geboren, 1,71 Meter groß und 64 Kilo.
Herr Becker steht heute bei uns seit gestern Abend plötzlich auf getretenen Herzschlagen und enge Gefühle.
Laut Angaben der Patienten hat er seit 3 Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Sie berichten, dass es in den letzten 5 Jahren eine solche Situation gibt, aber mit der Zeit diese 5 Jahre nicht mehr gibt.
Er berichtet, dass die Beschwerden mit der Zeit schlank geworden sind.
Er berichtete, dass vor 3 Monaten bei ihrem Hausarzt ein Magenspiegel durchgeführt wurde.
Die Schmerzcharakter sind dunklen und kolikartig. Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen besonders nach dem Essen auffällig sind. Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Nach dem Versuch liegt Schmerzintensität bei 4 von 10.
Begleitend ist Übelkeit besonders nach dem Essen auffällig.
Er berichtet, dass seit 3 Tagen gleichzeitig Durchfall geschieht.
Das sieht wässrig, dunkelbraun und breit aus, ohne Blut.
Die Vegetative ist eine Schmerzbedingte, die Schlafstörungen und Konzentrationen stört.
Die Vegetative hat eine Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörung bis auf unauffällig.
Die Gewichtveränderung ist sehr verneint. Bei der Vorerkrankung der Alamnesen ist eine Arterie der Hypatonie und eine Schmerzen.
Bei der Voroperation der Erwintersee ist mit 80 Lebensjahre ein Tonselektron durchgeführt.
Bei der allergischen Amnese erwähnt sie eine Erdnutzallergie. Sie reagiert mit Juckreis und Schweißausbruch.
Bei Medikamentos er nimmt regelmäßig Nebibolot 2,5 mg und Amlodipin 2,5 mg täglich morgens.
Er ist nicht Raucher. Er wurde 2 oder 3 Gläser Wein am Abend beacht.
Bei der Familienanalyse gibt es Arterie Hypatonie und Grüne Schta.
Auch mit 60 Lebensjahre hat der Vater Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Bei der Mutter ist Diabetes Meliothus Typ 2 bekannt. Sie hat eine Schwester. Sie hat Magen-Darm-Probleme.
Er ist verheiratet. Er hat eine Tochter. Er ist Kommunikation-Designer.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Reismagensyndrom.
Wofür spricht Reismagensyndrom?
Die Bauchschmerzen kommen nach dem 14. Jahrhundert.
In ca. 10 Jahren hat er eine Ähnlichkeit beschwert.
Vor 3 Monaten wurde bei ihrem Haus eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt.
Das Ergebnis war unaufällig.
Der Herzcharakter ist druckend, kolikartig.
Nach dem Versuch entspricht er der ausgeprägten Übelkeit und Durchfall.
Hat er Stress bei der Arbeit?
Er hatte zu Hause viel Stress.
Er hatte mit seiner Frau Probleme.
Er hatte auch Alkoholprobleme.
Bei seiner Schwester hat er Ähnlichkeit beschwert.
Was hat seine Frau ihm gesagt wegen Alkoholkonsum?
Schluck. Ich habe vergessen.
Schluck?
Was bedeutet Schluck?
Alkoholiker.
Was ist Ihre Differenz?
Die Diagnostik kommt aus der Gastroesophagealrefluxkrankheit und Akutkoronarsyndrom.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich...
Entschuldigung, Gastroesophagealrefluxkrankheit und...
Akutkoronarsyndrom.
Leidet er unter Luftnot? Brustmärzen?
Nein, der Patient leidet nicht.
Aber am Anfang hat er gesagt, seit heute Morgen, er hatte Herzschlagen und Engelgefühl.
Und der Patient...
Okay, was denken Sie daran, warum er einen Herzschlag, Engelgefühl, Probleme hat?
Ja, das bleibt nur eine Differenzdiagnose, um eine Herzursache zu ausschließen.
Das ist für mich sehr wichtig.
Deswegen möchte ich diese Optionen ausschließen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich habe eine andere Frage gestellt.
Was denken Sie, warum er einen Herzschlag oder Engelgefühlprobleme haben kann?
Der Patient ist 42 Jahre alt.
Der Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt.
Und der Patient hat seit heute Morgen Herzschlagen, Engelgefühl und...
...Akoholkonsum. Deswegen könnte ein Akutkoronarsyndrom sein.
Ja, aber ich möchte hören, er hat viel Stress.
Stress kann auf schnelle Herzschlagprobleme verursachen.
Schmerzen kann auf schnelle Herzschlagprobleme verursachen.
Und er klagt über Durchfall.
Hat er einen Erbruch?
Ja, erbruch? Nein.
Erbruch auch nach dem Tversa?
Erbruch auf Elektrolytstörungen.
Durchfall kann Elektrolytstörungen verursachen.
Und die Störungen oder Elektrolytenveränderungen sind auch die Ursache für Herzschlag.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich möchte diese Antwort hören bezüglich Ihren Patienten.
Sie haben Recht.
Natürlich ist der Diagnose Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Aber die erste Maßnahme, die erste Stelle steht, ist Stress.
Aber ich habe ihn immer vergessen.
Nein.
Eigentlich gesagt, nicht bezüglich seiner Diagnose, bezüglich seiner Beschwerden.
Stress ist eine Beschwerde, Durchfall, Erbruch und Schmerzen eine Beschwerde.
Alle diese Beschwerden können Herzschlagprobleme, schnelle Herzschlagprobleme verursachen.
Ich möchte diese Antwort hören.
Das ist eine sehr breite Frage.
Was könnte für den Herzschlag oder Herzrasen verursachen?
Sie haben Recht.
Dann gibt es Elektrolytverlust, Flüssigkeitverlust, Schmerzen und Stress.
Ich meine bei diesem Fall.
Deswegen möchte ich nur die Beschwerden des Patients hören.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde gerne als Erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Labo Blutbild, Nieren und Leberwerte und Instruktionwerte.
Herzensüme bestimmen lassen oder kontrollieren lassen.
Ich schreibe eine in Ruhe EKG.
Ich werde mit Ihren Hausarzten in Verbindung setzen.
Für die Ergebnisse der bisherigen Magenschwiegerung.
Wenn es nötig ist, eine neue Ösafarogastrodendonskopie verabreichen.
Eine gastroenterologische Konzellation.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema.
Wenn es nötig ist, eine neue Ösafarogastrodendonskopie verabreichen.
An welcher Situation oder an welchen Beschwerden würden Sie noch einmal Magenschwiegerung veranlassen?
Eine neue Blutung, Gewichtverlust, Schmerzenteste, Steigerung und ...
Gewichtverlust, Schmerzenteste, Steigerung und ...
Und familiäre Belastung.
Ja, das reicht.
Die Veränderung der Beschwerden.
Es gibt sechs oder sieben Schritte, aber ich habe nicht ...
Aber Sie müssen nicht alle Ursachen nennen.
Ein paar. Blutungen, Gewichtveränderungen, Best-Symptomatik, genetische Belastung und Veränderung der Beschwerden.
Ja, das reicht.
Okay.
Als Therapie würde ich gerne diese Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Diese Patienten würden ambulant behandelt werden.
Als Iniziativa Anarchetika, Antispasmodetika und Protonpomphalema verschreiben.
Und dann Lebensstilveränderung und Alkoholkarenz und Ernährung, Entstellung.
Patientenschulung ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich natürlich wie ein physischem Konsument.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Herr Özyübal.
Ekrem, wir werden die Fragen gleich wieder in der Hand sagen.
Da können Sie sich die Fragen selbst ansehen.
Es ist wichtig, dass Sie sich in der Situation ein bisschen auf die Vorstellung stellen.
Sie haben heute den Herzrasen gesagt, dann den Bauch-Mersen.
Sie haben es seit 10 Jahren gemacht, Sie haben den Doktor gesagt.
Dann haben Sie die Fragen zum Bauch-Mersen gesagt.
Normalerweise kommt der erste Patient mit dem Herzrasen, mit der Ngegevle.
Dann macht man den Bauch-Mersen.
Dann sagt man am Ende der Ngegevle.
Dann macht man die Ngegevle.
Dann geht es um das Backlight-Symptom.
Es ist nicht so, dass ihr es nicht benutzt.
Es ist schön, wenn ihr es benutzt.
Aber nicht das zu vergessen.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel das Ziberichtet sagt,
dann verbreitet ihr etwas über Schmerzen,
aber es gibt kein das.
Ziberichtet, das Zieschmerzen, bla bla bla bla bla.
Und dann das Feel.
Es gibt keine Probleme.
Aber wenn ihr das nicht sagt, dann geht es nicht.
Das könnt ihr auch ohne das sagen.
Aber dann müsst ihr das Feel auf den zweiten Schuss drücken.
Ziberichtet, das Schmerzen, Zint, bla bla bla bla.
Das sind grammatische Fehler.
Aber das kann man von dem, was man das hier sagt,
mit einer das bezeichnen.
Das hat ja eine solch eine Problematik.
Ziberichtet, das Zint, Schmerzen,
das Zinth, Schmerzen, Bla bla bla bla bla.
Aber das ist besser.
Ihr habt es sehr schön gesetzt.
Wenn wir auf das gut sitzen,
das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das.
Das wird wirklich wunderbar.
Das ist auch sehr einfach.
Das war das Problem.
Das war die Ob.
Sie sind bereit, das zu stellen.
Ich denke, das könnt ihr.
Nein, ich mache das auch zu Hause.
Ich mache das auf der Strecke.
Ja, ich danke dir.
Ich hoffe, dass es dir besser geht.
So.
Okay.
Ich glaube, es sollte die zweite Ipek abgehen.
Hier, Ipek.
Ich kann heute auch nicht die Kamera öffnen.
Du kannst es.
Okay.
Reis, es ist wirklich immer schwer,
mich so zu verabschieden.
Du hast keine Kaltklingeln gehört.
Ich bin ein kleines Patient.
Ich habe gesagt,
ich liebe keine leidenschaftlichen Patienten.
Reis hat gesagt.
Das ist warum ich da bin.
Ja.
Ja, woher?
Was ich hier herkomme?
Oh.
Es ist wirklich
anstrengend.
Du hast die erste Versage.
Dann die Baphysi Mersin.
Dann Anne Hebech,
Begleit Symptom,
Vegetative Anamnese,
Weita.
Die Beispiele sind klar.
Das war einfach, oder?
Du sagst, du solltest es machen.
Genau.
Ich verstehe.
Aber du wirst es machen.
Ich kann es rausnehmen.
Ich schenke die nebende Anamnese.
Die ich hier normale Anastasie.
Und ich sage es dir.
Ich weiß noch nichts von dir.
Meine Wörter sind wie Reisdarm.
Die Rakete estão vor dem Protokoll.
Schiprischt Fild
Erwend un nötege infos
Das ist ein bisschen komplex.
Genau, er spricht viel und kann sich auch nicht ausbreiten.
Er hat viele Psychosomatik-Besetzungen.
Er weiß nicht, welcher der wichtig ist.
Er sagt es hier, aber ich sage es für die echten.
Er sagt es von dort, und so ist es schwierig, sie zu beherrschen.
Er sagt es, und du wirst ihn beherrschen.
Es ist schwierig.
Der Grund ist, dass ich Psycho-Psychiatrie-Sympathien nicht liebe.
Es ist nicht einfach, die Patienten zu beherrschen.
Es ist schwierig, solche Patienten zu beherrschen.
Es ist sehr einfach.
Man kann sie nur knapp auf den Knopf legen, sie verlieren sich.
Das ist auch leicht.
Also, der Prof. Sumeir weiß noch mehr, dass es den Effekt der Vella-Faxxin gibt,
und es verhindert.
Es hilft nichts anderes.
Ich sage das mit meiner genannten Erfahrung.
Eine kurze Note.
Danke.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, aber bevor ich Ihnen einen wichtigen Gast
mitteile, habe ich einen Anruf aus dem Labor.
Frau Bergheim, Kaliumwert von 2,6 mmol pro Liter.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich erniedrigt und entschiebt eine Hypokalämie.
Darf ich jetzt meinen Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Aber bevor Sie mir Ihre Patienten vorstellen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen nach Hypokalämie stellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, gerne.
Was ist der häufigste Ursache für Hypokalämie?
Dieuretikabnahme oder dieuretikainnahme erbrechen Übelkeit.
Auch Durchfall.
Nicht Übelkeit, erbrechen Durchfall.
Ja.
Jetzt können Sie Ihre Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Tobias Becker.
Er ist 42 Jahre alt, geboren am 1.2.1964.
Er ist 1,61 Meter groß und wiegt 460 Kilogramm.
Er kommt zu uns wegen seit heute Morgen Herzrasen und enger Gefühle im Brust.
Die Frage nach Brustschmerzen und Atemnot ist unauffällig.
Er berichtet auch seit drei Tagen über Bauchschmerzen ohne Strahlung.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist drückend und kolikartig.
Ja, nachdem gestern Erklagt über Erklagt über die Schmerzen nachdem Tofu die Schmerzen
gestern Abend nach dem Tofu verziert.
Normalerweise hat er Unverträglichkeit gegen Scharfessen.
Er erwinnt auch zu Hause viel Stress.
Verstärkt Faktoren dieser Schmerzen ist Postprandial.
Er erwinnt auch, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie von Hausarzten erzielt.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie erzielt.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie von Hausarzten erzielt.
Durchfall, das ist aus Bereich wässrig, aber kein Blut.
Nachdem Tofu belastet er auch Erbrechen, dann fühlt er sich besser.
Begleitend sein sind Konzentrationsstörungen, Müdigkeit.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie von Hausarzten erzielt.
Als vor Erkrankung hat er seit zwei Tagen Bluthochdruck und Arteriellehypertonie.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor zwei Tagen Bluthochdruck und Arteriellehypertonie erzielt.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Wochen Bluthochdruck und Arteriellehypertonie erzielt.
In der operativen Anamnese findet sich eine Tonsillektomie vor fünf Jahren.
Bei der Allergenanamnese erwinnt er, dass er auf Schweißausbrüche und Pyruritis im Mund reagiert.
Er hat auch Unverträglichkeit gegen Scharfessen und Reaktion auf Durchfallüblichkeit.
An der Noxon-Anamnese berichtete er über den Alkoholkonsum, zwei Gläser Wein am Abend, Drogenrauchenkonsum würden verleint.
Sozialanalystisch ist er Kommunikationsdesigner, verheiratet. Er hat auch eine Tochter, aber er erwinnt viel Stress zu Hause.
Die Familien ergeben Bluthochdruck und Grünerstaff beim Vater und Diabetes mellitus Typ 2 beim Mutter.
Er ist voll geimpft. Aufgrund anämnistischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Reismargendam-Syndrom.
Er hat Bauchschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung, Durchfall ohne Blut und der fehlende pathologische Befund in der ÖGD oder Ösefakulasodionoskopie vor drei Monaten.
Er hat Stress im Leben und manchmal im Arbeiten. Er spricht für Alkoholkonsum.
Die Differenz-Diagnose kommt an akute Koronare und akute Gastritis.
Um die Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen, sowie Vitalparameter aufwachen, Inspektion, Palpation, Überprüfen, Überwachen.
Außerdem wichtig ist, EKG zu schreiben, um Herzkrankheit auszuschließen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbilden, die ich in der Klinik habe, ausfüllen.
Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Troponin und Cardiac Enzyme, Herzenzyme, Elektrolyt, Blutzucker, Nierenwerte und Lebewerte bestimmen lassen.
Natürlich würde ich auch Ultraschall durchführen, Echo meine ich.
Anschließend werde ich das Ergebnis der ÖGD erfragen und ein psychiatrisches Konzil anfordern.
Um die Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich eine Ambulanttherapie machen.
Zunächst würde ich den Patienten symptomatische Behandlung planen, also Flüssigkeit, Analyse, Antiemetik und gegebenenfalls Protonpomphema und Antacita.
Außerdem empfehle ich eine Alkoholkarantäne und regelmäßige körperliche Bewegung bzw. Gymnastik oder andere soziale Anleitungen.
Das war alles.
Vielen Dank.
Es war eine gute Verzucht.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Ich habe schon ein paar Schreie.
Wie oft haben Sie erbrochen? Wie sah das erbrochen aus?
Gibt es Probleme beim Stullgang?
Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen? Welche Konsistenz und Farbe hat der Stull?
Ich habe schon ein paar Schreie.
Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
oder so.
Die Beispiele auf der Füße sind wichtig, um den Stress zu verstehen.
Oder Sie können etwas wie Belastung-Physikos sagen oder Sie können mit den Beispielen auf der Füße
beweisen, dass Sie das verstehen.
Es gibt auch viele verschiedene Ursachen.
Es ist nicht genau erblich, aber es gibt auch verschiedene Gründe.
Es ist nicht erblich, aber es entsteht durch den Druck.
Sie können einfach bequeme Schuhe beweisen, wie Sie hier die Reaktionen in Richtung sagen.
Was anderes war, Professor Çetin?
Was anderes? Wir haben Kürnaşsitr gesagt, wir haben Schülük-Scheppich gesagt.
Ich habe es bei der Schülük-Scheppich immer so gemacht
Ich habe das nicht hier gesagt, das habe ich bei Akrem-Abi überlegt.
Er fragte mich, ob ich das so bin.
Wenn er mir die Alkohol-Nahme gefragt hat,
wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie?
Die nenne ich nicht Schülük-Scheppich.
Aus medizinischer Sicht ist der tägliche Alkoholkonsum so viel.
Der Alkoholkonsum kann die Ursache ihrer Beschwerden sein.
Haben Sie versucht mit Alkohol aufzuhören?
Normalerweise habe ich die Reaktion, die ich gemacht habe,
bei der Alkoholmikte zu sehr.
Weil Sie sind schuldig spektrisch, das ist nicht gut.
Aber ich habe versucht, dass der Alkoholmiktat zu sehr ist,
dass er mit den Beschwerden zusammenkommen kann.
Ich habe versucht, das so zu sagen.
Was bedeutet das?
Natürlich bedeutet das so viel Alkoholkonsum.
Ich habe nicht die Wahl, das zu sagen.
Ich wollte den Patienten direkt sagen.
Der Herr hat die Frage gestellt, ob man die Reaktion von Magne Spiegelung
in der Reaktion von der Reaktion von Magne Spiegelung
nicht vermittelt hat.
Er hat die Frage gestellt, ob man die Reaktion von Magne Spiegelung
in der Reaktion von Magne Spiegelung vermittelt hat.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, ob der Sport-Tribe
die Reaktion von Magne Spiegelung vermittelt hat.
Weil es Zeit für zwei Reaktionen ist, habe ich die Frage gestellt.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, ob die ÖGD wieder eröffnet wird.
Ich habe nicht davon gedacht, dass ihr Haus etwas übersehen hat.
Aber ich werde natürlich mit ihrem Hausarzt verbinden.
Und ich werde es erfahren.
Dann können wir die ÖGD wieder auf den Ausgabe bringen.
Ich denke nicht, dass der Doktor etwas von uns sehen kann.
Ich werde mit dem Doktor über die ÖGD-Reaktion sprechen.
Dann werden wir uns entscheiden, ob er wieder reinkommt.
Die Reaktion ist nicht eine Ersatz-Tribe für den Sport.
Bitte nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ohne Arztrechnung ein.
Medikamente sind keine Ersatz-Tribe für den Sport.
Das kann gefährlich sein, weil Medikamente für den Nebenwirkungen haben.
Medikamente sind nicht eine Ersatz-Tribe für den Sport.
Bitte nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ohne Doktor-Öneris.
Das kann gefährlich sein, weil Medikamente für den Nebenwirkungen haben.
Das war die Reaktion.
Wie habe ich es vorgegeben?
Ich habe mich vorgegeben, weil ich heute Morgen aufgetreten habe.
Laut Angaben des Patienten ist das Herzrasen plötzlich attackartig aufgetreten.
Der Attack hat ungefähr 15 Minuten gedauert.
Er hat seit drei Tagen bestehende Oberschmerzen.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen nach Versailler von Tofu plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen nicht ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzen sind dumm, kolikartig, persistierend, progredient.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerzen verstärken sich bei Bewegung, während sie sich nach Erbrechen verbessern.
Darüber hinaus erwähnt er, dass er seit 10 Jahren LKW-Schwerden hat.
Deswegen war er vor drei Monaten bei einem Hausarzt.
Damals wurde bei ihm eine Ösefogelgasrodionoskopie durchgeführt.
Aber ohne Pathologie schäme ich mich.
Ich habe eine Differenzialdiagnose mit Gasroenteritis und Akutpankreatitis.
Ich werde Lippas und Amilas bestimmen lassen.
Als Apparativ werde ich Bauchultraschall, Abdomenultraschall, Stördiagnostik bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde einen Konsül in der Abteilung für Gasroenterologie und Psychiatrie anfordern.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Die Patienten sollte als symptomatische Behandlung wie Analgetika, Spasmolytika, Antiemetika,
gegebenenfalls Protonpomphema erhalten.
Lebensstilveränderung spielt hier eine große Rolle.
Zum Beispiel, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr auf Gewicht, aber Gewichtrediktion, Ernährung umstellen,
regelmäßige Sportstreiben, Alkoholkaranz.
Ich habe auch einen Konsül in der Abteilung für Gasroenterologie und Psychiatrie bestimmen lassen.
Ich möchte mich an diese Patienten fragen.
Ich bin besonders für die Verdachtdiagnose, die die Patienten beantworten.
Ich habe hier in der Abteilung für die Verdachtdiagnose, die Reisdarmes-Syndrom,
versucht, das zu beantworten.
Das kann man auch so beantworten.
Aber Reisung, Reisung, Hesurssrung.
Des Darmes.
Ja, des Darmes.
Reisung, ihr es Darmes und ihr es Magens,
das kann ich beantworten.
Reisung ist für sie nicht ein langer Termin,
wie für Sie, wie für Ihre Darmes und für Ihre Magens,
wie für Ihre Darmes und für Ihre Magens.
Reisung des Magens und Darmes, oder wie ich es beantworten könnte.
Ja. Normalerweise ist die Reisdarm-Syndrom ein Abwechslungsstück.
Also ein Stück, das ihr alles nachher ausüben könnt.
Deswegen ist es mir sehr nützlich, in der Ecke eine Reisdarm-Syndrom-Stück-Stück-Stück zu haben.
Aber leider gibt es so eine Verkaufsweise fast überall.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es solche Verkaufsweisen,
damit die Menschen sich an die Erinnerung befinden.
Was ist der grundlegende Faktor, der die Reisdarm-Syndrom für uns denkt?
3 Monate vorher wurde Ozefagus, Gastrodeur, Dendroskopie, gemacht.
Es gibt keine pathologischen Befunde.
Es gibt eine Befugnis, Stress, etc.
Das ist das, was die Menschen denken.
Wie ist die Reisdarm-Syndrom?
Wenn es eine Verkaufsweise ist,
kann man davon antworten.
3 Monate vorher war das, aber es gibt keine pathologischen Befugnisse.
Ich war 3 Monate in der Gastroentologie,
da ich die Situation gemacht habe, war ich sehr bemerkt.
Sie benutzen diese Befugnis sehr, sehr sehr.
Sie sagen, sie sind für die Gastroentät, die Akute Gastroentität,
aber sie sind für die Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Es gibt viele Befugnisse.
Wahrscheinlich sind sie sehr verwendet und sehr verwendet.
Sie sagen, es ist im Vorplan, für die geflüchteten Patienten,
die sich um sie zu denken.
Aber es ist normal, dass es eine Befugnis ist.
Es ist eigentlich, dass es nach vieles gemacht wird,
etwas sein muss.
Das Wichtigste hier ist,
dass Ozefagus, Gastrodeur, Dendroskopie und Pathologische Befunde nicht sind.
Ich möchte mich um die Differentialdiagnose befassen.
Ich habe mich hier bei der Differentialdiagnose
mit der Pani-E2-Bereichung ausgedrückt.
Das ist eine sehr große Herausforderung.
Es gibt eine Arthralpustule, aber ich habe nicht gesagt,
dass ich Gastroentät ist.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Bruce Chimersen.
Ich muss also Gastroesephyse-Refle nennen.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eine M-Au-Küste.
Man muss eine Akute-Kroner-Syndrom beenden.
Man kann viele Differentialdiagnose wählen.
Aber nicht nur das.
Wähl zwei und fang an,
sonst kannst du viele.
Ich wählte die Akute-Pancreatitis und die Gastroentät.
Warum Akute-Pancreatitis?
Weil es mit Ozefagus-Refle ist.
Deswegen nenne ich Akute-Pancreatitis.
Ich dachte, dass ich eine Frage habe,
die ich an die Anwenderung stellen kann.
Ich habe eine Kurs für diese Kurs gemacht.
Deswegen kann ich ihr die Fragen stellen.
Ich denke, dass ich sie besser beantworten kann.
Warum Gastroentät?
Nach dem Essen wurde es erkannt.
Es gibt auch Durkfalli und Erbrehna.
Das war drei Tage.
Deswegen wähle ich Gastroentät.
Aber man kann das auch mit Ulcosventriküli nennen.
Man kann das mit Gastroesephyse-Refle nennen.
Man kann das mit Akute-Kroner-Syndrom nennen.
Es gibt also etwas,
das man sagen und erklären kann.
Das Wichtigste ist,
wie man das grundlässt.
Warum du das gedacht hast,
und was du antwortest.
Wähle etwas.
Wenn du das fragen willst,
dann sage ich das hier.
Das Wichtigste ist, das zu grundlässt.
Ich kann das mit Kapseln,
wenn ich an die Anwenderung komme.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen oder
eine Bedeutung?
Nein.